Why is iodine not a good idea for someone with breast cancer?
I do not have a thyroid cancer.
I take compounded thyroid medication and told there's a link between thyroid cancer and breast cancer.
Well iodine can be a good thing for breast cancer used acutely.
So I don't think that breast cancer patients should be on iodine or in turn.
The problem with iodine or the thyroid is the thyroid needs iodine in order to make T3s.
So that's a necessary component.
But when we take exogenous iodine in a supplement, it's basically taking a hyperdose of iodine.
You're really stimulating a lot of attraction to the thyroid gland by the immune system.
And the chance of you developing an auto immune thyroid if you're taking iodine long term,
the chance if you're developing a Hashimoto or Graves disease is almost 100%.
That's why I'm not a fan of taking iodine long term.
So if somebody just finds out they have breast cancer and they're going to take iodine for three
months, you know, that's fine, especially if it tests fine for them.
But if they're going to take iodine for a couple of years, the chance of them ended up developing
Hashimoto's even prior to any hypothyroidism, primary hypothyroidism is very, very high.
So that's why I'm not a fan of iodine.
So I am a fan of iodine in acute situations.
Let's say you have acute, you know, breast cancer or even acute radiation exposure
can protect the thyroid for a very short period of time.
But you have to be careful with iodine.
You want to take a full-based iodine, a kelp-based iodine if you're going to take it
and not long-term. That's just my opinion.